We purchased a grouty cheat and have it across the lower part of the bed, so only below the knees touch it, but since sleepy with this, I feel like it'll sleep as well.
Is there a adjustment, time adjustment with this?
Well, this, that's an odd phenomenon because...
Well, if you read the literature on grouty cheats, I mean, that's one of the things that they push is that people sleep better with it.
You're going to notice a great change in your sleep, you're going to sleep much sounder, you're going to have much better sleep.
To be honest, I haven't had anybody ever say that to me, that since I've been using the grouty cheat I sleep better.
Nobody's ever said that to me, nobody's ever said that in the Zoom call ever.
We don't really talk about the grouty cheat that much, but I also have never heard anybody say that they don't sleep as well with it.
I would just give it a few more weeks, I'd see how you do with it, because I just can't imagine that it would make you sleep worse.
I would give it a few more weeks just to make sure that it's stuck to something else, you know, that it's going to let you know, I'd sleep with you.
I'd give it a little bit more time.